HE BEGAN IN UKRAINTHSTORY FIRSTE
RUSSIAN WAGNEREAIT CONS  THE
FENCESND TNC
WHILWETE
A ON
ND THEM.
SATELLITE
G ANY CONSUCICIODOWN SOUTH,
OVER AN N
PLOT TO BLA MAJOR RIVERM.
UKRAINMIAND
OUAC ANO HE
G
DOWNST, ALOS
ISKS
R ANARSHAFFTON ISITUATION, SHE U
FRONDON.
Y N
Y RHIWE H1000 HOMESOUPOWER THII
OV
REGRE GN.
NTRAL WESTER
RISO  PEOPLE TO STAY
E DAM THAT YOU AREINTHERE E B
BEONTO THEAND NO THISSOMARMED OI
DAM WERE TO NSKYY ISME 80
IS, THPRESENED, IT WOULD NIT TOA
HE U REVERSED THOSALACCUOSTROY .
VEO JUST A THOUGHT OF THAT
ZELENSKYY, IS ALSO PLAYINGHEFLO.
>> SO THISMUTHAT HPE TNF'S A LE0
VESSELS ARE IN WTO FULFILL THEI.
UNDER  150 W BE OVER HALF OFTHIE
.BVUSEN
S OU FROM
RUSS IN RECENT WEE IE
TA ON THE
IDGE LSSIA TO CRIMEA.
TERROR AOULDEAD TO
THSINGHOUMANITNRITIME CORRIDORS
WHANTSO BES UKIN
AD
TO NEXT MONTH.
CLEAR THR RUSSIA,
EVEN THIS IS NOTNOUGH.
T WASHINGTON IS OPEN TTH MOSW
TO HELP IN UKRAINE.
INTEREST IN DIALOG
DOUBLE DOWN ONGGSS WIDER, WI
ADVANCDI S-
OOBUT, AS I SAID, INS MOME
WILLING TONGAGE INIPLOMACY
MEANS.
>> ELIER O, A THTEARE
FIRST  IN .
COMMUNICATPORTANCE O
UNCE, ANDERIS URGING THE INVES.
S OMHEUNTRIES SAY THAT IRAN MAY
HATEITY
ON THE UUSSIA
OSE DRON ABEING IDE E, ANDINTRNO
THE THEDEE RE IRA
INDIVIDUALS INA, RIGHT
NOW, WE NICALT AND TRAINING TO U
WT O
CAN RUSSIA, BUT IT I
R CAPABILIESTHE RUSSNS KILL
S  A
UKIAN INFRASTRUCTURE.
THIS, I WANT TOINNT.
WE FAL
WHERE HE RESEARCHES RUSSIA
FED CH,OMS
MILITARY SYSTEMS.
FRN
WE
ELL YOU THATRU IRANILESNDS?
>>OU FORITALLY TELLSRUSSIA LOOKR
ABILITY
GAP.
SPEAKS
USIASPECAN
FACT THAT  TO GET
LAQUICKLY FR PARTNLI ISI
CO OTHERIEALES
L PPT FIED ANDCONTUE
E INRN R
R L AND ECONOMICRT.FOIROU
REINFNGSION, H NAS EEVR  AND AI
S TO MILITARLOPAT POSSIBLY NG A
LITICA>>TH IRAN,
T IS IT BECAUSE IRR BECAUSE
REO
VO
>> I TDESTION.
E T  Q
ABOUTS
E.
I BECAUSA LOT D NT ENO
WI IS A Y
PRES ON CHIN BE ABLE TOSTATEWO
IRANN UNDER
TIR LESANCTIONS, NAVIGATE TH, EE
TIONS ATCEAI IISANS
LOGIES, ANTACTICS,ITER
EE AGAINST NOTBY TURNI A RELATIY
ABOUT THE IN
TH
RONES ON I
ENT?
WVERY
RTT THEYDR.THEY CAN CANEN
TWEEE $30,000 ,
OTHEALSO FLYING
ONWAVEAGAINST UKRAINIARG TO
ERWHELFE CNUMBER AND CTHFARA
IA TODAY HAVE
A COICON
AVRE